on est à bout dès lors bonjour la
préfecture de police dénonce un départ
en cortège sauvage de certains pompiers
professionnels en direction du faubourg
saint martin mais vous vous êtes au sein
du défilé déclarée entre république et
nation quelle est l'ambiance de votre
côté exactement à priori on est tout
simple de ce cortège qui a déclaré on
l'avait dit et de partage qui se sont
scindés y en a un qui est allé vers le
boulevard richard lenoir et je peux vous
dire que l'ambiance est assez assez
impressionnant puisque pour une des
premières fois et bien on se sent pas
très
c'est cette manifestation puisque vous
les entendez derrière moi il ya des
fumigènes et des péplums ici en tout cas
toutes les secondes
après concernant la mobilisation et bien
il ya énormément de monde et dorian de
deux pompiers qui sont présents qui ont
répondu présents et ils sont très très
en colère et ils sont tous en tout
avec des boules quies donc ils sont
assez préparés à ces prêts à affronter
cette manifestation ici
aujourd'hui ils seront en plusieurs
milliers à se mobiliser le cortège est
parti vers 14 heures au 2 place de la
république pour atterrir à nation ici et
il faut savoir que ce n'est pas la
première fois que les sapeurs-pompiers
manifes il ya eu plusieurs réunions
d'ailleurs à ce qu'on peut entre
l'intersyndicale des sapeurs-pompiers et
aussi du ministre de l'intérieur
christophe castaner il ya eu plusieurs
discussions mais ça n'a pas convaincu en
tout elle est sapeur-pompier qui
demandent plus avec des effectifs et
surtout une revalorisation des salaires
notamment de cette fameuse prime du feu
qui est aujourd'hui de 10% ils veulent
une augmentation à 28%
normalement c'est toujours en discussion
est aujourd'hui en parallèle de cette
manifestation et bien il est en contre
qui va avoir lieu aujourd'hui entre
l'intersyndicale et des sa portée et
pied et kris castaner c'est toujours en
discussion et vous l'entendez c'est
assez impressionnant et c'est difficile
aussi de pouvoir à vous parler
correctement puisqu'il ya beaucoup
beaucoup de bruit
nous en tout cas l'a commencée les
pompiers défilent dans les rues de paris
ils ont été rejoints par quelques gilet
jaune en tout cas pour l'instant il ya
eu un dispositif de sécurité qui est
assez important aujourd'hui avec des
policiers qui sont aux abords de cette
manifestation et qui la maîtrise pour le
moment merci mon âme ou dès lors en
direct de la manifestation déclarée des
pompiers à paris